e aí
eu acho que nossa repetição que você
unitária na sua mulé mc uma longa
história tem sempre obrigado para quem
tem dinheiro em que a um julgamento
bastante desigual em relação ao processo
de cuidados de saúde e acho que é
interessante nós analisarmos que
historicamente este conceito de medicina
para todos é muito recente o primeiro
serviço nacional de saúde nasce no reino
unido 1946 e esta percepção de medicina
humanitária além-fronteiras ainda mais
recente criação da cruz vermelha
internacional que é muito ligada às
vítimas de conflito na semeados século
19 um senhor chamado henri dunan prêmio
nobel da paz fundador desta delícia
organização mas ainda assim não tem a
própria muito aquele espírito da que eu
da proporcionalidade de acesso aos
cuidados de saúde em relação às
necessidades o primeiro intervenção
verdadeiramente humanitária é
curiosamente uma república de um
tô com vontade que eu conheço
relativamente bem em meados dos anos 60
um continue que os europeus
essencialmente franceses e também a
áfrica mais tarde no final dos anos 60 e
início dos anos 70 a criação dos médicos
sem fronteiras em que o lema é que a
proporção de entrega dos cuidados de
saúde deve ser a efetivamente igual as
necessidades o que será sempre uma ideia
utópica mais bonita de perseguir eu já
tive o privilégio de fazer bastantes
missões e sinto que há sempre uma
abordagem em relação as curiosidades à
em direção àquele que eu tenho vindo a
fazer as pessoas fazem muitas perguntas
quase como se eu fosse assim carinho
extraterrestres o que eu de alguma forma
compreendo porque eu estive efetivamente
em outros planetas
e eu acho que a pergunta que me fazem
mais vezes é porque tu vais
bom dia normalmente sorrio e penso para
dentro como é que é possível não ir não
há nenhum julgamento aqui nesta frase
mas é sempre aquilo que ilumina e depois
é que eu tenho pergunta de uma corrente
e frequência é que não tiveste medo
e eu sim eu tenho muito medo tenho medo
de ser ignorante tenho medo de não viver
inspirado tenho medo não ir atrás das
minhas motivações e tenho acima de tudo
muito medo de olhar para o espelho e não
gostava daquilo que eu estou a ver mas
este melhor do que as pessoas referem
das bombas das granadas dos tiros também
sinto mas é curioso que de longe o sítio
eu tive mais medo foi na cidade do porto
porque a antecipação dos acontecimentos
é a projeção do desconhecido nós não a
mente nos faz sofrer quando lá estou
olha a minha volta sinto-me mais um esse
dá bastante tranquilidade e de pouco
medo que existe é o momento que existe
eu não me sinto particularmente corajoso
e largamente ultrapassado pela motivação
daquele que ele sinta a minha volta que
estou a fazer e que de alguma forma
represente a
eu estou te perguntando ah mas muitas
vezes qual foi a pior a segunda pior a
terceira pior isso não é história nós
temos que ser qual foi a pior e aquilo
que domina se calhar a minha reflexão é
pensar na síria bombas a cair a casa a
tremer as fugas para o álbum que são do
estado islâmico o aparecimento da
poliomielite mudança já erradicada neste
país há muito tempo
oi gente também na dificuldade que tive
no iêmen dizem que a maior crise
humanitária dos últimos cem anos cerca
de cinco milhões de crianças estão em
risco de morrer a forma foi também para
mim se calhar missão mais intensa em
termos médicos em que eu muitas vezes
encontrei a proximidade do pênalti e
ainda assim para mim a pior missão foi
aquela que eu desisti foi aquela fui na
faixa de gaza não tem nada a ver com o
local tem a ver com o facto de que eu
achei que as minhas convicções não
estavam a ser fiéis aquilo que eu
acredito e tomar umas uma das decisões
mais duras mais dolorosas mais tristes
da minha vida que foi quase trair a
minha paixão e disse que não queria vir
embora
a empresa quando regresso missão as
pessoas perguntam então correu bem
o que que é isso de correr bem
oi lu tudo bem ele me presente quando eu
regressei no meu celular me fazer um
estas estas perguntas para pensava numa
história uma vez eu recebi o nosso
segunda cidade do iraque no norte se
vocês sabem tava ocupada pelo estado
islâmico durante cerca de três anos e
teve uma guerra de libertação terá sido
realmente a batalha mais dura dos
últimos tempos morreram 50 mil pessoas 2
milhões de refugiados 13 cólera de
centenas de milhares pessoa funcionário
muito triste uma cidade com 300 mil anos
que está absolutamente destruída para
todo sempre eu lembro que uma das recebi
uma criança com dois ou três anos que
tinham traumatismo craniano no contexto
do conflito e começou as mãos já
empolgada com tubo na traqueia se
possível muito bem exatamente o que é
que está a passar sabia que nós não
temos condições para tratar aquela
criança não tinha de cuidados intensivos
pediátricos nem nem tá aqui
neurocirurgia e então eu viro o meu
chefe e daquele eu tenho que levar esta
cria
em qualquer cidade de erbil que é
capital do curdistão iraquiano ficava
mais ou menos a três horas de distância
já tinha as estruturas hospitalares
bastante desenvolvidas e mais
rapidamente nos referindo a isso não
pode sair por questões de segurança
impossível e o que é que eu faço essa
para aquela sensação eu esta criança é
minha responsabilidade neste momento que
é que eu faço eu tenho é difícil eu saio
prognóstico não é maravilhoso mas no que
depender de mim então a alternativa foi
ensinar um enfermeiro como é que se faz
a ventilação durante três horas dentro
de uma ambulância sem ventilador entendo
tudo ser feitos manualmente uma pessoa
com conhecimentos relativamente às gases
em que eu tenho que em minutos treinando
para aquilo que é uma prova bastante
difícil e qualquer erro pode significar
a vida desta criança e do explicar
experiente lar assim com esta frequência
com este volume com essa intensidade não
há telemóveis por isso corra mal não tem
qualquer espécie de forma de me
contactar e estou ali com ela a fazer
e assim muito intensivo para que ele
parece que esta criança consiga
sobreviver essas três horas de viagem e
quando chegar ambulância para trazer
para levar esta criança para outra
cidade conhecia abre as portas da
ambulância eu vejo lá dentro de várias
crianças todas empoeirados todas
ensanguentadas algumas quase morrer
é realmente dos momentos mais duros da
minha vida em que pensei o que é que
estás aqui a fazer o quê que isso
realmente interessa
o existe resposta do correu tudo bem
é mas também há momentos em que a minha
cabeça vai para outro lado em que eu
penso que uma vez que recebemos uma
fornada de feridos de guerra em que
recebi um adolescente que tinha o corpo
todo cheio de estilhaços é um cenário é
difícil de absorver é medicamento também
bastante exigente porque nunca sabemos
qual dos estilhaços é que penetrou e que
está a causar lesões importantes
internas e rapidamente eu e o cirurgião
percebemos que temos que levar para o
bloco operatório e parar a hemorragia
uma equipa bastante treinada com a
máquina bastante aliada e que foi
relativamente rápido estabilizar um
traumatismo torácico e traumatismo
abdominal estado a sangrar bastante e
depois de várias transfusões e outras
atitudes quando eu percebo que a
situação está assim mais ou menos
controlada eu saio do bloco operatório e
dirigi-me a outra tenda externa um
hospital por montado entendes que era
uma espécie de cuidados intensivos tem
os dentes mais créditos também estavam
sobre a minha responsabilidade
e no momento em que ele sai da tenda
dentro de atende ar condicionado e
quando eu sair da tenda tá um 50 graus e
leva assim que parece que abriu o forno
assim que uma baforada de calor e e
cruza um com uma pessoa te reconheço
conhecendo o pai do adolescente que eu
estava naquele momento a tratar dentro
do bloco operatório ele carme e começa a
falar em ar de língua que eu não sei e
eu percebi que a minha volta não assim
mais ninguém e ele dirige-se a minha
está claramente a fazer perguntas sobre
o estado de saúde do seu filho e eu sei
dizer duas outras palavras em árabe eu
eu não tenho tradutor eu digo assim tá
me ligaram quer dizer que está tudo bem
e agora assim para mim e ajoelha-se
agarra-se as minhas pernas e ficar
chorar agarrada a mim e eu obviamente
sinto-me desconfortável eu pego nele e e
naquele naquele movimento quase que não
planeada ele dá um abraço e e fica assim
ali um momento muito intenso duas
pessoas que estão muito distantes que
não se sabem falar mas que sentem
obviamente um reconhecimento muito muito
grande e percebemos não é que todas
estas crianças e adolescentes têm
novamente paz a sofrer pelas suas vidas
e quando me perguntam também se correu
tudo bem eu penso me de alguns destes
momentos que foram super importantes e
super simbólicos para a minha vida e
para a minha profissão
e eu também não sou eu às vezes fazia a
ponte no hospital eram várias tendas
entre serviço de urgência o bloco
operatório os cuidados intensivos às
vezes e a ver os feridos ou atenda do
serviço de urgência e depois aí a fazer
a interação com o bloco operatório e uma
vez que eu entrasse de rompante o bloco
operatório e ver onde a equipa irá que
anos que trabalhava lá pessoal siga
temos de 300 canções para fazer rápido
preparem o material participasse por
quero ouvir historinhas temos no meio do
ramadão eles estão cheios de fome e seja
de cedo e desidratados e eu tenho lima
se pressão eles viram-se assim para mim
mas habitações aqui é um cotações da
cabeça rápido e eles começam a tirar e o
material às vezes não é barreira
linguística também e eu não é
simplesmente passamos na cabeça e assim
mas fazer aí mais cartaz abrir que a
água e engraçado porque passado meses e
anos quando ele falo com eles eles ainda
se viram para mim e me dizem aquelas
anotações da cabeça fundo das coisas
mais importantes para nós porque
o motorista de emoções que tive lá o meu
cê qualquer coisa mas eles se viram uma
sou país o seu povo a ser absolutamente
destruído e ela vem à mente quando tem
pessoas do outro lado do mundo que vem
para os ajudar e que de alguma forma não
é diminui do seu sofrimento e às vezes
com uma hora em tempos de guerra
consegue fazer coisas muito bonitas
e eu quando você muitas vezes a pergunta
então e as mulheres
oi e aí rapidamente vou para a minha
segunda missão que foi no paquistão
pessoalmente eu sinto mais complicada em
termos de repressão cultural em termos
de extremismo fundamentalismo e lembro
que perdi a conta a quantidade de
mulheres que morreram nas mãos
essencialmente por hemorragia party part
e foi também uma missão clinicamente
muito intensa eu amo determinada altura
eu estava a fazer uma formação de
reanimação de suporte avançado de vida e
e os homens e as mulheres não podem
estar na mesma sala que eu fiz uma
formação só para homens
o e de repente a médica ginecologista
quer uma espanhola pergunta me olha eu
gostava de que era preciso fazer também
para as enfermeiras e enfermeiras
parteiras nós temos na maternidade
bastante grande e eu posso te ver mas eu
acho que isso não é permitido para não
ela não sei vamos ver vamos começar como
é que foi permitido uma sala twitter as
portas abertas só mulheres desta vez e
foi muito estranho porque elas na rua
andam divulga dentro do hospital eu não
só com os olhos tapados e não olham para
mim não falam comigo não interagem não
fazem qualquer espécie de bilateralidade
desta comunicação e eu faço a formação e
é muito estranho parece estou a falar
para volts que não respondem não reagem
aquelas estratégias clássicas de tentar
olhar as pessoas nos olhos de fazer
algumas perguntas ao meio da formação
nada zero e 45 minutos a falar
completamente sozinho elas entraram no
deixei um caladas eu não faço
e aí quem são essas pessoas com quem
estou a falar e confesso que cheguei a
casa assim o caminho triste isso
eu tentei e depois perguntei a américa
espanhola olha então o que é que tu
achas que roubem e ela abre assim elas
adoraram
e eu senti um bocadinho do entediado no
que ela por exemplo estava a ter eu
tinha muita dificuldade em perceber o
mundo das mulheres mas percebia que as
mulheres que lá chegavam cheia de
condicionalismos mas chegavam claramente
um a uma parte do coração daquele povo
que eu nunca consegui chegar aí percebeu
com especial isso pode ser na nesta
pequena amostra que eu tive
e depois a pergunta que me fazem oscar
mais vezes é e qual é a próxima
e eu acho que neste momento se vocês
estão a fazer essa pergunta é por que
não perceberam nada aquilo que eu disse
ah e não perceberam que é que a medicina
humanitária não é aquele que motiva que
a resposta é claramente não interessa
não interessa onde não interessa como
interessa que o esforço o pensamento as
ações sejam proporcional sejam
proporcionais as necessidades e pressa
que seja tudo fundamentado numa frase
muito simples todas as vidas são iguais
e que nós temos que pensar se não for eu
então quem e se não for agora então
quando obrigado pela vossa atenção e
[Aplausos]
e aí